renault a acquis le créateur de nos
familles locales basé à epernay
il se rend chez pascal lecocq un
producteur de foie gras de bazin ville
pour récupérer ses commandes
hebdomadaire ça va ça va chercher des
malgré un jour d'hui derrière deux
opérateurs compagnies locales
c'est un site internet qui ne proposent
à la vente que des produits locaux dans
sa camionnette
ronan transport des fruits et légumes du
pain des brioches et des produits
laitiers
l'offre est variée 30% de nos clients
sont les entreprises donc soit des
comités d'entreprise soit des gens qui
sont allés directement sur le site et
qu'on me l'adresse de leurs sociétés
comme livraison et 70% ce sont surtout
les particuliers qu'on livre
essentiellement le samedi où les soirs
de semaine comme bombardier ouvert le
service existe depuis le 1er avril
dernier
le client fait ce compagnie parmi un
large choix sur le site
la commande et sans engagement le
montant minimum d'une livraison est de
20 euros à domicile est de 15 euros pour
les entreprises
le panier coûtent en moyenne 30 euros
par personne avec mon panier locale les
producteurs peuvent connaître la vie de
leur clientèle et s'adapter aux demandes
c'est une expérience intéressante c'est
un monsieur qui veut vraiment vendre des
produits de la région donc nous on
préfère travailler en direct comme ça
que avec des passées par des revendeurs
multiples et nombreux lacets direct du
vient chercher les produits des livres à
s était bien équipée d'un roi etc
donc il fait vraiment le décès sable que
les conditions soient réunies
comme c'est totalement libre on commande
ce qu'on veut au rythme où en veut aux
c'est pas comme un abonnement dans
d'autres dans les amap ou d autres '
mon panier locales enregistrent 250 à
500 commandes par mois